timmi Joe reviews anything reviewing
computer parts on YouTube look in the
competition hi there Timmy Joe
I recently had a comment where a man was
like I really like your videos but I
hate how you treat your hardware well
you know what if you don't like it
there's the ha no I'm kidding stay
please I need validation anyways rx 560
review pretty much a brand new one - I
mean it's QT it's like eating a little
graphics card what a little bees laid
out well boom well she's humming along
overclocked and running a little bit of
Unigine I figured I'd show you a few
monstrous video cards that are very much
overshadowed and outperformed by the
little devil here now I know let's just
get the elephant out of the room yes
there is a big case to be made for
getting gtx 1050 over this little guy or
1050 TI yes but I've got some key points
to make about why this thing's good and
sometimes you might just be in the
situation where you have one of these
available whether it's used or whether
it's whatever and then you know you
rather pick that up or maybe you have a
free sync monitor which is my first
point free sync support sure 4 gigabytes
of vram out the gate booyah
I actually even have a version that
doesn't have an external power connector
and it performs admirably so yes so this
is a dual GPU massive video card granted
it's like eight years old now but GTX
295 will see a review for this at some
point on the channel
blows this thing out of the water in
fact it doesn't even have DirectX 11
support but more to the point two GPUs
in this thing and it's confined drear am
is a hundred or 1792 megabytes of ram so
this has way more than double booth out
of the question
let's talk about uh you know one that
actually an AMD card that actually might
be worth picking up if you could find
one only one gig of VRAM on this 6870
and you know garbage doesn't even touch
it
we've got two left here we've got the
original Fermi the one I cook eggs on
actually I got two of these now so I
might do a little SLI at some point but
yeah just fixes things but and then we
got the sapphire
7850 we'll see a review on this soon to
a budget car I thought it might be a
good idea it'd probably be kind of like
a step up from this guy two gigs of VRAM
on this thing this thing kills it so
let's look at the overclock we've got a
little overclock here she starts off at
around 1150 to 1200 I've got mine up
another hundred or so on the core 213
I've seen people even go to 14
especially if you have one that has an
external power connector but you know
what I actually did a little bit of
research and found that most people say
there's not much difference maybe one or
two fps
when you're pushing it that extra
hundred megahertz now you can max out
that memory slider though and get some
improved performance but is that for
geeks of VRAM on this thing you know
worth it yeah debatable to two gigs
minimum these days but is this thing
going to do way better than a 1050 cuz a
1050 only has to ginks know what 1050
still beats this even if it swaps you
know a little bit on the edge over to
your system memory this is just a more
powerful GPU but it's close this is
close
especially when you fire up
a little overclock so let's go ahead
we'll shut this off we'll shut we'll go
over here we'll shut my recording off
and then we'll get to what I'm talking
about here the RX 560 in 2018 with five
of the newest / most played games of the
last six months or so okay we're gonna
look up some benchmarks in just a few
moments but to my point poof
this would be the AMD Radeon HD 7850
which would be of all the graphics cards
I just had on the table the big ones
with the crazy copper heat pipes and
stuff sticking out of them it would be
the most powerful actually it's you know
got a little heat pipe on there and it
gets a first-rate graphics core of a 50
175 okay so let's look up that I didn't
do this yet not even even put this in a
system and I don't even know if it works
but I do know that my our our Sharma GTX
480 my NVIDIA Fermi card I have tested
that on my own system boof and on this
exact same test bench it gets a graphics
score of 40 140 135 so what does the
little rx 562
[Music]
Bouchet it does 7520 8a boom that's a
good score that's actually a really good
score when you consider my itchy
eyeballs sorry it's actually pretty good
score relatively you know compared to
you know GPUs have passed like this
being a budget option you know from a
little while ago this would probably be
in the area of the r9 270 I recently put
any budget system and sold and you know
what this beats it just by smidgen so
boom what are the specifications well
this one is there's like five versions
of these I don't know why but this one
has a overclock of 1234 gaming mode you
know an overclock mode of 1234 boost and
this one has all the compute units now
we maybe you don't know maybe you do but
if you're looking at a 560 you have to
make sure that it's not this weird
cut-down version that AMD started
selling with less compute units it needs
to have 16 see use there are some ones
like 12 I think they will not have the
performance I'm showing you here today
but this one's an overclocked version
you know it's a one that's got the full
kit and kaboodle and it doesn't do too
too bad a boof so yeah she's actually
not too shabby on anyway egg right now
that this is still fairly expensive 175
for this card but we all know we just
got over the GPU pocalypse and prices
haven't exactly busted down but I can
see this card in the coming months
dropping well below a buck 50 and at
that price it certainly is great for the
budget gamer and it is ace you know
definitely a well-earned upgrade over
the AP use that AMD just launched the
2400 G this this will definitely do
better than that if paired with you know
a similar processor so there's that to
consider and with that dedicated vram
and that dedicated GP
it's gonna be better as we'll see for
benchmarks in a second if you're looking
to do online gaming or maybe you know
record some of your gameplay or
something like that this will be that
better option than that APU reminds you
it does have a minimum you know well
it's around a hundred and fifty dollars
if you look for a good deal on one so
let's go ahead and actually show you
some benchmarks we want to check out
what this thing will do I didn't run
like my full test suite what I was more
concerned with was the very demanding
titles that just launched so we're gonna
see Far Cry 5 we're gonna see Final
Fantasy that just launched on the PC did
a little bit of benchmarking with that
we're gonna look at Wolfenstein even
though most people for some reason don't
like that game actually understand it's
kind of boring but we'll see that in
there too as that's baulkham title and
should do very well on this and then let
me come back we'll do a little summation
and of course during the benchmarks we
will look at Far Cry or sorry fortnight
benchmarks as well as pub G so [__] it
out Timmy Joe
[Music]
oh so you live how I hang on my hardware
you fuzzy little guys Heather we're back
so she's cute you know you know it's the
smallest one on the table and it's the
most powerful so it's pretty cool now
let's go ahead and take it apart hi and
we'll just have a look at you know
what's what's under the hood and we'll
talk benchmarks what I did was I didn't
put msi afterburner on with the FPS
numbers on initially for any of these
titles because what i wanted to do is
with my free sync monitor over there i
just wanted to let the games load
whatever they thought was best for
settings now that only works in some
games sometimes you just have to kind of
maybe guess at what would be available
for it but i wanted to see how it felt
without really scrutinizing the numbers
too much and I was like really
pleasantly surprised it's it was so
worth opening this thing up I was
pleasantly surprised to see that I all
the games felt really good even when in
Final Fantasy II I loaded it up it
didn't feel amazing but it felt the
console playable look how tiny that
freaking thing is let's regard damn
Nicolas boom so yeah it didn't feel half
bad you know far cry was I've been
playing far cry with this card for the
last like three four days and it's been
you know totally playable at high
settings getting near 60fps especially
when paired with my free sync monitor
because I have a Samsung 4k monitor it
has built-in free sync that is a thing
that you'll see on a lot of budget
monitors and it really helps that with a
little tiny baby GPU like this and
getting some seriously decent numbers so
although you know it's a hundred and
fifty dollar graphics card you can't
expect to too much for it but if you're
considering some used options
you can't beat a card that doesn't
require you to change out a power supply
if let's say you're buying an OEM system
like Dell or HP you know with a core i5
in it plop this in there it's gonna
freaking game almost as good as the
benchmarks you just saw and you're gonna
have a wonderful time playing and yes
you're gonna have to limit yourself a
little bit to medium settings or you
know but a 1080p is always gonna be an
option and it's not gonna be half bad at
all and what was best was pub G play
fine and medium settings I was getting
near 60 fps and I was not ever worried
about skipping frames especially since
pub you've pretty optimized lately even
it seems on these little guys on AMD
GPUs but you know in fortnight's buttery
smooth a trip high graphics no problem
at all and then you could play your new
games like you know Far Cry 5 at pretty
decent settings - and you're not gonna
have you know anything to complain at us
so all in all this is an amazing little
budget card that you can pick up and if
you buy the right one with the right
compute units you know you're not buying
this give down version and you're buying
one that you know doesn't have an
external power for a low-end system or
you know go ahead and buy one but this
is a pretty Brinke dink cooler in fact
all of the ones on here that are you
know a lot hotter suck a lot more power
have giant copper heat pipes running
through them this thing beats it out
again
and it has just a solid block of
aluminum cooling it with you know two
fans there are definitely versions of
this thing that have even less for
cooling on it you know this one gives
you that little bit of thirteen hundred
megahertz on the core clock you know
it's pretty cool so I'm not watching me
join Instagram or Twitter I wanted to
tell you that if you go below right now
there'll be a link to this very one the
gigabyte one's like over two hundred
dollars which is just stupid but this
should be pretty much an equivalent GPU
to this it's an msi version for gigs you
know everything's there the compute
units are there and she's only 163
dollars not bad at all you know let's
check it out it's nemesi and you can
plop this in any system and away you go
genku and if you're in the market for a
brand new GP Ewing or you know a little
worried of their scarce use stuff in
your area and you're a little worried
about buying a used graphics card you
could pick this up and you know as long
as you're paying that hundred and fifty
around you're gonna be pretty satisfied
and I think it will hold its value
either around hundred dollars for the
foreseeable future unless something
crazy happens with new Nvidia or
something like that but you know for the
most part she's a dandy little guy so
I'm out watching me enjoy scrammed
Twitter hit up that Amazon affiliate
link below you're gonna buy one of these
pick this one up there's lots of other
stuff actually I have a little page
where you can go see some things I've
reviewed some things I recommend if
you're doing any buying on Amazon that
really helps out the channel it's a huge
up skiddy upped up and always there's
patreon we're near $100 go get me on
patreon for God's sakes help the channel
out help the channel grow and you know
there's you could always send me some
old hardware to lots of people do that
this was a submission by a viewer and I
got to thank him like crazy because this
came from overseas for God's sakes I'll
see you guys in another video thanks for
watching
tons of stuff upcoming freakin amazing
stuff here's a preview do you know what
that is because I didn't until recently
I'll see you guys know video thanks for
watching
[Music]